Concord is the last one which of course
is San Francisco that's where the live
album was recorded in that city
it's completing the circle yeah you know
wonderfully you know well you got I
can't wait that's gonna be a tough one
isn't it I think so my all my [ __ ] of em
I got a lot of family here tonight
they're all going to be at Concord and
we'll have some sort of party afterwards
I think celebration you know it's a
celebration are you looking forward to
that
no no because this is just I don't want
to ever want it to end you know because
it's so much enjoyment it's as I've told
you before it's my passion is to play
music but even more on stage with an
audience I was put here to do that I
think and I just it will be a hard one
to say goodbye mm-hmm have you prepared
for it in any way now I never prepare
for anything
I never even prepare what I'm gonna say
on stage so now it's all it's all
stream-of-consciousness I never you know
I never think about anything beforehand
yeah you know so you're not worrying
about it or anticipating it or that's my
only way of not anticipating it more
yeah I try not to think about this thing
coming to an end